welcome to the program tonight my name
is Conan O'Brien and no I am not
cosplaying as penny wise let's get that
clear right now it's a similar coloring
and I do frighten children yeah it is
great to be here at comic-con I almost
didn't make it this year I was in the
hospital yeah true story I was in the
hospital passing two Infinity stones I
know this crowds like that means there
are four left more in space reality time
sorry sorry that's only 90% of you
things were getting a little tense here
at Comic Con this year yeah I noticed
that yeah earlier today I saw a
president Trump till three Klingons to
go back to where they came from yeah
thank you thank you though the word is
trenchant look it up what else is going
on in this world interesting news I did
you hear this Star Wars just released
some new merch true story one of them
yeah okay one guy excited that's really
bad news for the marketing team yeah oh
really more okay that's great you know
there's a true story they released more
merch one of them is a Jar Jar Binks
lollipop yeah yeah yeah the Jar Jar
Binks lollipop is described as not sold
out
no one's excited about that hey got some
good news good news Comic Con has agreed
to stay in San Diego for three more
years that's good Comic Con Comic Con
has agreed to stay for three more years
in San Diego meanwhile the Chargers left
in 2017 so so congratulations because in
San Diego nerds
last longer than jocks
[Applause]
you know what's gonna happen I'm gonna
fall in love with doing that and I'm
gonna go off the edge of the state and
fall on this person right here what's
your name Andrew you look so much like
me as a child stand up place again this
could be the child I've never
acknowledged there is
Wow Andrew went from incredibly shy to
like he's like Mussolini you were such a
shy like who me oh I couldn't yeah
[Music]